so we begin with some breaking news from
malaysia where the immigration
department has defied a court order and
has deported more than 1 000 asylum
seekers and children
to myanmar earlier a malaysian court
granted the migrants a temporary stay
that ruling followed appeals from human
rights activists
malaysia had promised not to deport
rohingya or
un registered refugees that's because
myanmar is in the middle of a crisis
following this month's
coup the military is coming under
increasing international pressure
the g7 a group of the world's wealthiest
nations has condemned the junta for its
violence towards protesters saying the
use of
live ammunition is unacceptable three
protesters have been killed since
february the first
they are refusing to back down until
deposed leader aung san tsuchi
is released let's go straight away to
tony chang our correspondent who joins
us live from the thai capital
of bangkok and tony we'll come to the
deportation uh in just a second
um but first up what is the latest with
the protests are we seeing them at the
same scale as
monday
not on the same scale but they are still
going on large numbers out on the
streets in yangon
others down in the south in darwin and i
think the protesters are very
keen to maintain the pressure they
worked up yesterday
on the military to get that message
across they are not going to back down
despite the intimidation and the
crackdown we saw particularly in
mandalay on saturday when two protesters
were killed when uh when the security
services opened fire
we also saw uh in mandalay the funeral
of one of
the two people who were killed there
those people have become a sort of
representation for the protesters
of the kinds of sacrifices they feel
they go prepared to make
um and they're absolutely adamant
they're not going to back down
and in addition in yangon today uh
protesters targeted the indonesian
embassy after they heard that the
indonesian foreign minister was trying
to
convince southeast asian nations to
persuade the burmese military to accept
a compromise
uh where a new election could be run the
protesters say they are
adamant uh the the the election results
of november last year which the nld won
overwhelmingly should be respected uh
the indonesians however say
that this is not true they are not
planning any such scheme and as a
sidebar to this we have the story of the
melee how malaysia has
broken a court order and has deported
more than a thousand asylum seekers and
children
back to myanmar
indeed and this came as something of a
shock a couple of hours ago
after we heard earlier in the afternoon
that
the malaysian court had decided that all
of those um
those asylum seekers would have a
temporary stay
until tomorrow when a further ruling
would be made
we've heard that 1086
myanmar nationals have been put on three
myanmar navy ships that were waiting in
malaysian navy docks and have now set
off to be
repatriated and the malaysian
immigration chief says that
all of those on the ships have gone back
voluntarily and there weren't
any refugees on those ships
but the court case involved six people
who the unhcr
said or more than six people who said
the unhcr said they had recognized
as refugees uh and uh and minors who
one of whom's parents we understand are
still in malaysia so
at this stage it's unclear whether they
have removed some of those people
and kept them back for that second court
hearing tomorrow but
i think something of a shock also
they've defied the court particularly
sending back
so many people to a country which has
undergone
a military coup on where some of those
come from ethnic minorities who could
very much be under threat when they
return into the hands of that military
government
all right tony thanks very much indeed
for that thank you
well let's speak now uh to phil robinson
who's from human rights watch
uh and to get further uh i have thoughts
on this um
phil first of all say there we were just
speaking a couple of hours ago and the
refugees
deportation was on hold but not so they
are now deported and heading back to a
country
in the midst of a coup yeah this is
outrageous and unacceptable
the malaysian immigration department
apparently thinks that it is above the
law and outside of the courts
i mean there was a clear kula lumpur
high court order that stayed any action
to remove this group until the court met
tomorrow
they have defied that all i can think is
that
apparently uh the malaysian immigration
department cares more about the needs of
the myanmar navy
that sent three boats to pick these
people up and their inconvenience than
uh respecting a court uh in malaysia
and what we've seen not only is the
director general of immigration
uh previously lied about this group you
know when he claimed that there were no
refugees or asylum seekers among the
1200 be sent back
but you know now he's basically
operating outside the law
so he needs to be investigated the prime
minister i must order an investigation
of him in the immigration department and
i think the national human rights
commission suha khan
must also immediately investigate what
more do we know about this group
who have been repatriated or on route to
going back to myanmar
uh in the sense of are they asylum
seekers
what's their makeup we i mean
the the experts in these matters which
is the u.n refugees agency unhcr
has not been allowed to access uh these
1
200 people and that's actually what we
were asking for this whole period is
that
allow them to have access allow them to
check who these people are uh
you know find the people who are uh
refugees with unhcr cards find the
people who have a legitimate claim to
political asylum and pull them aside uh
if
if they don't have a claim to asylum or
they're not a refugee and they're not a
child being separated from their parents
then you know they can be deported but
the reality is that none of that
happened
uh unhcr has been completely left out of
this
and the immigration has just again done
whatever it wanted completely outside
the law
and what are your concerns now for these
people as they head back
to a country in the state of crisis
well my concerns is that they are going
to face hostile interrogation and
possible persecution
uh by the military junta and its
representatives in the navy who picked
them up today in in
in malaysia uh that there's gonna be a
lot of uh
hard time that they're gonna be forced
to try to explain
why they went to malaysia this is a
government now in
in myanmar that is a military junta and
that has
traditionally looked very badly at
people leaving the country without
permission
and uh they could they could be
prosecuted for leaving myanmar
uh without authorization and
what about any recourse is there
anything any action that can now be
taken
well i think that the investigation uh
into the director general of immigration
and his immigration department
needs to happen and i think they should
face uh severe penalties uh for defying
the court
i think there also needs to be action uh
based on the
concerns that we and other human rights
groups have raised that
people here were probably asylum seekers
and refugees in that group
you know this is a completely outrageous
violation of international human rights
law by the malaysian authorities and
and i think that the immigration
department has to pay for it and if they
order
if they were ordered from higher up uh
the people who gave that order have to
be held responsible as well
uh phil robinson deputy director of
human rights watches asia division
thanks very much indeed for that
thank you